good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can wait
patiently patience is for the impatient
that in fact when you're getting started
in your in-laws are making faces at you
and you're not sure if you're gonna be
able to pay the rent and you don't know
why you're living in Brooklyn to begin
with and you're gonna have to move back
to Florida it's easy to say you know
what I need to go faster to pick up
these scraps to pick up these scraps and
sometimes what that does is it gives you
the foot up to get to the next level but
sometimes what that does is it just
makes your scrap collector and that one
of the things that we see when we look
at the work of people who have put
really big ideas into the world who have
built online platforms right is that
they got there by being patiently
impatient or impatiently patient
whichever way you want to just oppose it
that if you look around at the blog's
you read or that the people you respect
online or the organizations you want to
work with the myth of the overnight
success is just that a myth
that you know the much-vaunted twitter
was a failure a complete failure for two
years nobody used it and if they took
the mindset of well if it doesn't work
in two weeks we got to go do something
else you never would have heard of it
you're trying to get to that next level
and you're impatient and when I talk
about impatient you know what I'm
talking about I'm talking about rate
road rage you feeling me you look you
don't know what happened you were just
driving you is chilling somebody jumped
in front of you start going slow
whatever before you know it you out the
car y'all about to scrap impatient you
you at the bank I'm you getting
frustrated because the line is low you
in the grocery store you see the long
lines and you going through it I'm
talking about listen to me baby steps
baby steps because to be impatient right
to be impatient it's not something that
started off huge it's a real small thing
that occurred in your life and now we
want to get a grip on it listen to me
I'm trying to tell you to hold on why
because it's all coming together just
because you can't see remember what I
told you before that mental 42 is
telling you that even though I don't see
any external evidence I still believe it
remember we talked before that site
versus vision and you can see it when
it's not there that's right we got some
practical things because it's coming and
you're about to mess it up listen to me
about to mess it up for yourself you
trying to do the right thing you like
yeah I'm doing the right thing but I'm
not seeing it yeah you don't you're not
supposed to see it that's not what it's
about
you keep going through the process
knowing that the process is perfect and
that you're eventually going to get to
the prize alright so the first thing I
need you to do is I need you to change
your thinking I told you that's where
everything starts it all starts in the
mind and so mentally if you could tell
yourself you saw it the ritz-carlton the
Westin Hotel you saw the speaking
engagement you saw first quarter you saw
second quarter you see you you are
witnessing your boy blow up right in
front of your face from where we started
to where we are almost two years ago are
you hearing me so so small step mentally
I need you to do me a huge favor
mentally I need you to create listen to
me embrace embrace the I don't mind
waiting mentality I don't mind waiting a
year I don't mind waiting to it listen
to me some of you will never get again
what you're supposed to get because if
it don't happen for you in 30 days you
giving up you quitting I dare you to
embrace I don't mind waiting that's what
happened to your boy it took almost 18
years for me to get to where you see me
at today and I did my weight in the
first year I did
my weight in the second year I didn't
mind waiting the third year and so you
got to embrace that I don't mind waiting
attitude if it takes six months if it
takes a year if it takes ten years I am
going to weigh it out all right so I
need you to do two things for me the
first one is when I tell you to wait I
heard a great theologian tell the story
when they use the term weight it's like
serving we're not talking about just
waiting idly and doing nothing he said
it's like a servant you're serving right
like at a restaurant you are serving so
while you're waiting listen to me while
you're waiting to pass that bar exam
study while you're waiting for your
mirrors to get better don't just sit and
wait watch some dishes serve your wife
flowers serve your husband I don't know
while you're waiting for that
relationship between you and your son or
you and your daughter to get better
don't just wait by the phone
do something buy a card write a letter
listen to me take a trip to the town
that they live in visit a job take them
to lunch like I don't have the slightest
idea but don't wait idly right serve you
saw us thank God is Monday every week
you saw us
SoundCloud the app while we were waiting
to blow up while we were waiting to make
our dreams become a reality
we weren't sitting idly all right so I
need you to change your mindset I need
you to serve I don't mind waiting I need
you to serve alright here's my final one
I need you to do some I don't mind
waiting exercises when you go to the
restaurant and I listen to me been there
done that right when you've been there
done that when you got to wait 30 40
minutes to sit down like think of some
activity you can do in the process I
used to go to the grocery store and look
for the longest lines I'm not playing
with you I went to the I sat in the
longest lines on purpose I didn't go
through the quick boys why cuz I needed
to work on my patience when I went to
the bank I went to the long line are you
hearing me to work on my patience when I
would drive I'd see the longest line on
the freeway that traffic jam I would get
in the longest line because I knew if I
worked on my patience that my patience
would bring something in my character
that would actually help me to get to
the next level I really believe that I'm
a bridge right I'm pulling equally very
aggressively from both sides that I'm a
human contradiction that if you really
watch the show and throws people off as
they get deeper into my content
that often times I'm saying things that
contradict themselves because the truth
is they both live in real life at the
same time and it's about finding that
cadence and balance the guide through I
am massively at a global level patient
but on a practical level and an
execution level I'm very fast right so
it's it's really it really is religion
and church right like at the highest
like at the theoretical act at the at
the gray levels a patient long game I'm
aware that as long as I'm alive I'm
playing the businessman game and and and
it doesn't end tomorrow and if it ends
tomorrow I don't know the outcome anyway
because I'm dead right and so in but in
real life I understand it's a race and
the X speed is a variable for success to
me in a big way hustle and so the
patience and speed are very much rubbing
against each other but it's like the
diamond comes from that right like and
so that's that's the thing that I think
about I don't I I find it very easy to
do vote you understand there's people
that are both in practical and
philosophical terms and they have
different outcomes aka
there's people that philosophically are
not patient they're impatient and
they're fast and they look like the bad
version of what I am right there like
hustlers and they're like like doing
everything for themselves and they're
not patient they don't care about the
long game and they're just gonna take
and they're just gonna take and take and
take and gonna take fast and they're
gonna gather and and I think that that's
society the game rewards them and
there's a lot of millionaires and
billionaires that didn't do it the right
way and that's what I think they look
like then there's a lot of people that
are massively patient and slow and those
are the Norma's amount of people that
you know in a business context not in
life they're probably some of the
loveliest human beings that I've ever
been made because they're slow and their
patient and everything just lovely and
let's just like sit on the porch and you
know drink peach tea for the rest of our
lives and like like go slow just go real
slow like let's sit and look at stuff
like like let's sit on the porch and
look like look at stuff like a car just
drove by great like I'm
like that you know it's not interesting
to me either and and so that exists so I
actually think what what I do exists a
lot I think there I think it's the
likable you know aggressive person and
that's you know they're out there and
there's a lot of winners that are good
people that I really think that and I
think if you look at my analogies this
beam part is really valuable right like
like if you're speedy and selfish and
impatient you know I think the other
thing about the the lack of patience and
fast you don't have to be a bad person I
think it leads to mistakes right
that's another variable layer here you
know it's funny that my brain went that
first narrative here's a second
narrative you're going fast you're not
patient so you rush the outcome and you
leave money on the table you sold a
company too soon
you uh you weren't as profitable as you
could have been because you missed
things because you didn't see it because
you weren't tactful and so you know I
think I think it has essence of strategy
you know somebody once said to me about
Boehner Garrett you guys are so
interesting he was trying to zing me a
little bit about we weren't strategic
enough
he said you're so interesting but he's
like when you get into the house I feel
like a lot of times you guys just run
through the glass window instead of
opening the door like it was a funny
analogy and then I looked at him and
said yeah but we're gonna own all the
homes sometimes an indirect route is the
quickest way to get there
sometimes you gotta take a little long
to achieve the things you wanna achieve
in life
so don't be in a hurry be patient be
patient everybody this instant
gratification Instagram is to this be
patient that's not gonna happen as
quickly as you want it to happen a lot
of things gonna happen that will catch
you off-guard and so therefore you've
got to deal with and handle it as it
comes and not only that but that faith
and patience drives you into action you
got to keep moving
and keep plugging away and the Far East
they have something that's called the
Chinese bamboo tree the Chinese bamboo
tree takes five years to grow and when
they go through a process of growing it
they have to water and fertilize the
ground where it is every day and it
doesn't break through the ground until
the fifth year okay but once it breaks
through the ground within five weeks
it grows 90 feet tall now the question
is does it grow 90 feet tall in five
weeks or five years the answer is
obvious it grows 90 feet tall in five
years because at any time had that
person stopped watering and nurturing
and fertilizing that dream that bamboo
tree would have died in the ground
I can see people coming out talking to a
guy out there watering and fertilizing
the ground that's not showing anything
hey what you doing
keep it out here a long time man
and the conversation in the neighborhood
is you go on a Chinese bamboo tree that
right yeah that's right well even Ray
Charles and Stevie Wonder can see ain't
none show
you know how people gonna do you so how
long you been working on this how long
have you been working on your dream it's
good and you have nothing to show this
is all you've got to show people don't
do that to you
and some people ladies and gentlemen
they stop because they don't see instant
results it doesn't happen quickly they
stop oh no no no you got to keep on
watering your dream and when it began to
happen they stopped laughing they said
look whoa look at it
patience is really about trust
I see trust as like planting a seed when
you plant a seed in the garden there is
droughts that come there are insects
that come so you have to tend the seed
but if you tend it it wants to grow and
it will produce amazing things so you
choose your intention you plant a
beautiful seed you direct yourself to a
creative project to a visionary way of
living to a community of family a part
of the earth to something that is a gift
that's given to you that you can give
back and then you see what happens and
to understand that is an enormous gift
patience sometimes can be misunderstood
as inactivity if I'm patient it means
I'm holding back and I'm not going to
give myself fully to something but it's
not that at all patience or trust is
really waiting for the right season
again like surfing you don't just get on
your board and paddle you wait for the
right moment in the wave patience allows
a kind of deep inner trust that we have
the capacity to be with the matrix of
life and when you quiet your mind and
open your heart and look to the mystery
then it's not even a question of
patience it's a question of being home
and your home exactly where you are
which is where you always are in the
reality of the present it doesn't mean
that we don't weep it doesn't mean that
we don't care deeply about the losses in
the world in some way as we become
trusting patient or grateful even
grateful for the difficulties we also
allow ourself to be touched more fully
by life I think as entrepreneurs we are
not great waiters in general I think
that's part of what also makes us
successful is that we want things to
happen and we want things to happen now
I think what happens though quite often
is you wait for something to happen and
in the meantime you're not doing
anything you just keep putting all your
energy trying to make this one thing
happen and the reality is a lot of times
you have to wait for some things because
you are dealing with other people and
other people's timelines and schedules
as well and so the key for me is you
hustle while you wait you're grinding
you're working you're making a
connection you're waiting to hear back
instead of just waiting to hear back you
are grinding and hustling more maybe on
the same path and maybe in different
directions so as an example I'm working
on getting an interview lined up with
Tony Robbins I'm in touch with his
assistant and we're trying to figure out
a date a place everything that can work
great you know I need to hear back I
need to figure out when that dates gonna
work for both of our schedules in the
meantime I'm winding up other interviews
right I did one with Gary Vaynerchuk I
did one with Chris Gila boy did one with
Ryan holiday I'm doing with Lois house
I'm doing one with James Ulta Chur
lining up a whole bunch of different
interviews I'm also hustling on my
YouTube channel I'm making these videos
I'm grinding out in the comments I'm
researching new clips to add to the
channel right I'm spending a lot of time
I'm hustling while I'm waiting and so I
think for me at least that's the key
there will be times in your life that
you are waiting on somebody else and
it's insanely frustrating and you're
doing everything that you can to move
that forward but as long as you've done
your best like I can't move this forward
anymore until you hear back from
somebody else they've made a decision
don't just give up and wait for that to
happen you're hustling in the background
and other things and all the other
things that I'm working on all the other
YouTube videos and all the other
interviews that I'm doing
only help me when I make the next
contact with Tony Robbins people because
now I'm bigger than it was before
because I've done more work and open up
other opportunities and haven't even
thought of yet
so hustle while you wait I love to know
from you guys how frustrating waiting is
for you and how do you handle it what
have you learned from some of the clips
here today that might also help you in
handling the weight I'm really curious
to find out leave it in the comments
below and I will join a discussion
I made this episode of believe life
because Karen Singh asked us to so if
there's another topic you'd like me to
cover in the next edition to believe
life leave it down in the comments as
well and you'll see we can do thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon
if you're really frustrated and you're
just hating it right now the easiest way
for hope to go out the door is to get in
a hurry yeah see if you get in a big
hurry you're pushing you're pushing
pushing you're in a big hurry
now you don't sense the wind anymore you
don't sense the momentum the progress
anymore you're just more more more more
more MORE
you're in such a big hurry to have more
things that sometimes it feels like you
have nothing and the reality you do but
a part of achieving anything is having
the patience to work towards it having
the patience with other people sometimes
we lose hope and other people not really
that we lost hope we just spot for got
to be patient with them you know you
need to give a lot of patience to the
people in your life if you're going to
sustain hope for them and for your
relationships with them patience is a
critical element it's not discussed a
lot but you know what it's so
fundamental to having hope to be patient
with it being patient is very important
for a successful CEO it took 18 months
for us to get our first customer but
that patience is what the next 18 months
we got thousands of customers millions
of users and hundreds of thousands of
jobs into the system if you have to put
the patients as part of the goal in
terms of business it takes time to build
a foundation things that matter take
time so if you have a lot of patience if
you put as much patience into building
your business as God puts in to us I'm
just think about how much patience and
forgiveness he has and it helps us
become the individual that has a greater
relationship with him our businesses are
the same way it takes time it takes time
to build the relationship submit' takes
time to have your investments come to
fruition it takes time to understand the
mechanics so believe in yourself and
believe in your patients when you have a
lot of patience and passion and you
combine those two things you can create
a tremendous amount of abundance in your
life